not happened
to the left good to go
my name is nicholas irving i'm a former
third ranger battalion special
operations sniper
and currently a new york times
best-selling author i spent six years in
special operations
and i'm known for are known as the
reaper for 33 kills and about a
three-month time span in helmand
province afghanistan today we're going
to be looking at a few sniper scenes in
[Music]
movies
no one ever really does that
ah no
his use of the equipment was really
really good he has his
you know his pad to lay on he has his
range finder
you can measure the wind barometric
pressure the altitude density altitude
his dope book the word dope is an
acronym in snipers and it actually
stands for
data on previous engagements so he can
go back and refer to all these things
that
he's engaged before that and have like
some good reference point
he applied all of his dope and his data
to the scope itself i
rarely see that in movies where you know
he applies the elevation and the windage
the impossible portion about this whole
thing was the actual
shot itself the the train is moving way
too fast
you have to you know defeat gravity in
some ways so you're aiming up and the
bullets dropping
almost down at that distance and
shooting through glass
panes of glass angled glass and
different types of glass
may deflect and alter the bullets flight
you'd have to be
one really really really really lucky
guy
or after that get up and go walk on
water
but now that i see it i almost want to
simulate it but it's kind of it'll be
almost impossible to simulate
i can't find a target moving at a bullet
train speed um yeah so this is a
very basic very basic bolt action rifle
uh remington it shoots a 6'5 creedmoor
round
very very fast round small caliber but
i use it essentially because of the
speed of it i use it to defeat the wind
if it's a lot of wind or
shifty winds or anything like that it's
a good bullet because of the
velocity of it how fast it's moving he
had a suppressor on his i don't have one
but for
you know overseas work and stuff like
that if i had to make a
one shot one kill i would probably take
something
along the lines of a bold action rifle
then you have your bipod legs and that's
just for you know stabilization
have a scope and of course you have your
trigger and
and butt stock there's not much to a
sniper rifle
his eye position his cheek weld where
you put your cheek on the rifle itself
rick rest his was
pretty much perfect on his uh you'll see
in movies sometimes the guy will have
his
eye pressed all the way up on the scope
and you know unless you want a huge
black eye and a nice you know
bloody eyebrow wouldn't do that i keep
both eyes open
that way i can use my peripheral vision
to you know keep my situational
awareness
good body position behind the gun you
want your body to be
you know almost perfectly in line with
the gun that way when the vehicle comes
back
you know you're not bouncing off target
you can get a good follow-up shot
your skeletal structure is going to
support all that recoil if you're canted
off to the side
that gun is going to hop so being
perfectly behind the gun as much as you
possibly can be
that was a solid 80s still look maybe
even a nine it was the shot itself
it was uh a one i would never take that
shot
range 900 yards
that was good that was really good um
the term all the dialogue uh you know
between
spotter and shooter were really really
good
uh he kept his firing hand on the rifle
the entire time
while he adjusted the scope with his
left hand
900 yards though definitely not going to
take a headshot
and with that scope it wouldn't even
look like it's that close it
would look you know he would look way
smaller than that
permission to fire what the frequency
are you on
we got air i'm calling it in you have
permission to take the shot
tough break you were just going to shoot
one guy i think where
it gets a little uh a little wacky is
where the guy busts into the room and
tells him to stand down
uh snipers like to set up um sniper
hides and
are they're essentially in a slight ride
and there's booby traps and stuff like
that in there
maybe that colonel or the guy who walked
up the stairs maybe
may have hit a trip wire or being you
know
maybe engaged by the sniper team itself
once it came into the to the room like
that um but if they had permission from
the colonel i would have taken the shot
anyways
i'm not too sure where this guy felt
that he had the authority to do that
um i would have taken that shot this is
that is a moment it's a it's a weird
moment where you're looking
through the scope and you see your
target and you know for a fact that hey
i'm about to
in this guy's life it's a life-altering
emotional rollercoaster experience
i can see the emotion behind it scale
from one to ten for that one i'm giving
that one a
nine
stop touch that light-colored grass
sniper at your feet it's exactly like
sniper soul
the one that that sniper scope is not
that reticle inside the scope is nothing
like
what you would use in real life you
usually have these little uh
mill dots on there like little circles
and you have four of them
on each uh the horizontal plane in the
vertical plane inside the scope and
they're used for measurements
so let's say for example if i had a
target that was 40 inches tall
and i wanted to find out how far away
something is
but what i would do is take the 40
inches and multiply it by a constant
which is 25.4 and that comes out to 1016
uh and i would take the mil dots and
let's say if the target measures two
mills high
i would divide 1016
into uh by two and that comes out to 508
so i had 508 yards
on the target on my distance and i would
apply that to the scope of my gun
damn going to that trigger squeeze that
was not really good you want to use the
pad of your finger he kind of curled the
entire trigger finger
as a precision weapon you're looking at
harmonics and stuff like that
so imagine like a tuning fork you want
everything to be as smooth and
less friction on the sides of that
railing inside the gun as possible so
having the trigger come straight back is
what you really want to look for
um not so much of that curled trigger
finger and it's exactly how they use it
in sniper school where the
the you know the instructor he's telling
the guys on the outside
hey come in you know sniper ate your
feet x y and z
it's pretty much exactly how it works
all right you won this one come on out
soldier how did you get that close to me
sneaking up on someone is extremely
tough
uh because of this the stalking portion
it's not really an easy
tactic and not too many guys are good at
being that sneaky
for the training portion i would give
this one
a seven
it really doesn't get any better than
that um
d i i grew up with this movie and what
he does is actually just wounds the guy
usually if you wound someone it's going
to take one or two more individuals to
come
pick him up or drag him out so you get a
chance to kill
three targets instead of just one really
good tactic if you're a cruel sniper i
would have never done that
um i was you know us military we trained
one shot one kill
the enemy sniper how he put the burlap
over his rifle
and to match the inside of the burlap
behind him inside that little bell tower
that is perfect the germans actually
mastered the skill of cycling from
camouflage to
long-range position
snap bang theory he hears the bang of
the rifle
our first fin diesel gets shot the guy
gets shot and he goes down then you hear
the crack of the rifle
and he's it's almost like lightning and
thunder so he's counting
really quickly to determine how far away
the sniper
is and he's picking picking uh a known
likely and suspected positions where
that enemy sniper may be
everything about this clip is just how i
would do it you know it's
the calmness behind him how he creeps up
and puts the rifle on the rocks and
slowly gets behind everything and you
can barely even see the guy
you know behind that rubble the way he
blends it in with the rubble and his
position everything look at that that is
almost
by the time you saw it was too late
that's target detection at its finest
and then that that is something you do
teach
or learn in cyber schools target
protection td the instructor will place
out like a toothbrush and
a one bullet or something very a
protractor
at 100 yards away and as a sniper you
have to find
10 objects the issue with this shot
it's a lot like the carlos hacknock
story where you know he shoots and the
bullet goes through the scope and
hits the guy in the eye he's shooting at
an upward angle
at a target up in a bell tower and how
bullets fly
if anything he would have just got the
guy in the head
he'd have to almost be you know directly
in line at a very
short very close distance for that
bullet to travel
all the way through the scope and then
hit the guy in the eye
i've been in an exact position like this
pinned down by an enemy chechen sniper
but he was 800 yards out uh we never got
him
uh he didn't get us but it was
essentially like playing volleyball with
bullets and he did that for about three
hours
uh he had us pinned down with this spike
rifle he was in
a position just like this guy and save
it robert ryan the enemy sniper
and we were my reconnaissance team and
my sniper team were in a small little
four-foot
diameter hole penned down and surrounded
for about three hours
uh the whole firefight lasted almost the
entire day like ten hours or something
like that
so i give this one a nine point
he's five he's moving he's moving to the
building follow him you got him
got him
really nice
he's down that was really good uh i
think well
there's a few few things that i saw
wrong with it um
going to well the sniper dialogue was it
was okay
it wasn't the best sniper dialogue that
i've ever heard it was the second
shot where he moved 20 meters to the
left of the building
really good sniper dialogue the spotter
talking on
the sniper to the target set after that
first shot with that 50 cal
went um as a spotter he should have
called out immediately
hey you're like two mills low inside
that reticle is like mil dots mill
radiant circles in there and
they're used for measurements um at that
time when he missed that shot
the spotter the guy on the scope should
have told sniper
hey aim up two mills and you know send
it again i
should have never let that guy get up to
run
window at the window at the window
this shot where he's engaging the
targets in the building the two
uh guys in the building a little fly on
the eye uh that was pretty neat to add
in there
uh it shows that dedication to the you
know
uh to the spotter into the sniper team
but you're in this little bubble only
you exist
nothing else does and the single shot
with the
50 cal is i've never seen it never heard
of it
but i guess it makes for a good movie
not too too bad on the skill for one to
ten i'd give it as a sniper team
of four
that was really really good now that was
uh long survivor is one of the most
realistic
movies i've seen when it comes to combat
i've used that same rifle overseas
in afghanistan my deployed rifle was an
sr-25 but i used that one
when i was a designated marksman that
shot right here it's
i mean it's real it's real it shoots a
five five six so it's not a very
powerful round or anything like that and
being in this environment i was just
getting into special operations
first day in the barracks when the guys
were coming back in
stateside after rescuing marcus trail
you deploy every six months overseas and
we were averaging
about 120 missions per 90 days
um your average troop won't even touch
that in a year
the unit i was with holds the record for
killing and capturing
the most high-valued enemy targets uh in
the global war on terrorism in iraq or
afghanistan
whether you're a navy seal which is
special operations your green berets
special forces
marine force reconnaissance you know
delta force
whatever you want to you know all
special operations and
very small group of guys they go through
a very very grueling experience
and they get the best of the best the
best training they could be sleeping in
your attic and you wouldn't even know it
that's what special operations is like
that's why that's what i like to think
about you know
being a ninja it's like being a ninja
this should be like the modern
day standard for wartime movies this is
the tim
in my opinion
i had a chance to meet chris kyle uh in
vegas one time
bradley cooper played it pretty looks
like chris kyle
chris kyle was a navy seal uh sniper and
he's accredited with
the most kills in the u.s military as a
sniper but before him was carlos
hathcock and
i believe his spotter carlos had contact
93
i remember hearing about chris kyle when
i was in afghanistan and there was rumor
about this navy seal guy who was like
you know had over 100 kills and i was
like there's no way
um but yeah yeah way
for one shot one kill i would say
dude that's extremely tough
um in sniper school you know you learn
how to shoot one
mile and and you do it in training every
once in a while but
the odds of a one round first hit
uh not likely i do like the fact that
they use that little
that flight time to show you how long it
takes for a bullet to travel
you know one mile it's not immediate
and you know with that distance you're
looking at so many factors that come
into that
i'm even looking probably at a mile i'm
starting to calculate for a coriolis
effect as well
and that's where you take the the spin
of the earth and
you're you know taking that into
consideration and putting that
plugging it into the formula that long
flight time the earth is still spinning
you know a thousand
you know miles an hour or whatever um so
you have to kind of
you know account for that uh they did
put a lot of work into it
you know chris is a good guy um but for
movie aspects i'd give it a
oh wow i'd give that one about a seven
that was epic that was a really i was
almost playing along in my head with him
is you know who would i take out
first and it was in that order i would
take out the guy in the shower first
going back that was a i think that's a
mozart golf rifle
made it's pretty accurate for open
sights
that position shooting through something
like that
is one it's extremely scary you have to
understand
your you know how your rifle works
uh how much you have to aim up so your
rifle so what you're looking at
you're not actually hitting the
bottom portion of that brick wall and in
the beginning he even sets his range
where he licks his finger
he's taking off the mud uh on that slide
so it's like a little slide
if you ever have a chance to look at the
top of an ak-47 uh he slides that whole
lever up and that raises the rear sight
and that lets you it adjusts the
elevation it's essentially like a scope
just without the scope
dude the most i've taken out in a row is
five a good sniper
a good sniper not even a great one a
good sniper could pull that off
how he wraps his hand around the sling
to make it nice and tight that is
perfect you never really see that movies
they teach you that in sniper schools
yeah that was really fast
really good look at that wrap over the
top nice and tight
boom that's perfect let's say 70 percent
of my shots overseas were from the knee
um and at that distance with that rifle
that's not a hard shot that's definitely
not a hard shot he's got to be less than
100 yards away
that's a 10 that's a 10. i cannot
argue with this whatsoever
before i was a sniper i was a machine
gunner with a 50 cal
um that round is devastating where she
uses that little laser finder
probably not going to happen ever that's
a very
you know fine object point the sniper in
the window should have known
where the elevator was at or where she
was going to be shooting at
anyways but
people don't look like that when they
get hit with the 50 cal it's usually
just
a puff of
moisture and mist the guys returning far
from the inside
essentially just killed or injured a
bunch of civilians on the street
i do like the use of the sniper who how
she's using the
the bed frame and not like out the
window like you see in most movies
and yeah she's backed away so yeah i
would have used that same tactic
as long as that rifle's not hanging out
the window
she should be fine and she's not
shooting through glass
i'm giving ah
a three
not happen um there was a shot like that
back in the 90s it was a police swat
sniper
uh less than just 98 yards away where he
shot the pistol out of the guy's hand
but at
this distance that wind you're gonna
think you're on top of mountains and
a true sniper would never take that no
matter how good you are
if you look at her her hair her hair is
not blowing that much
so there's obviously not a lot of wind
on target
i give that a good three four five mile
an hour wind
you wouldn't dare take that shot i would
debate even taking a headshot
at that distance at that distance to a
real scope
you wouldn't be able to see you'd be
able to see maybe a black
toothpick by the time you put your
crosshairs
on whatever you think was a shotgun the
crosshair itself would probably cover up
the shotgun
if you go back and you can see where his
scope is
not covered in the front portion you see
that black hole there
any good counter sniper would have
picked out all this white terrain
and then boom there's this black circle
there
marky mark would have been hit a long
time ago if i were on that other end
prior to this going off him shooting the
guy off the guy saying i'd give it a 5.
5.5 with that i give it a 2.
what is it
the sniper who's on that team mercenary
team has a large 50 cal that gun weighs
about
38 pounds and the guy soaking wet was
maybe 150 pounds
and he's moving miles and miles and
miles at a high rate of speed with this
rifle
i wouldn't do it but what they would do
is separate it into two pieces so
one guy would have the upper portion the
other guy would have the lower
uh portion of the rifle kind of
distributes the weight it's
about as tall as i am you know i've had
to jump out of a plane with it one time
portion of it and it's a extremely
uncomfortable gun to carry i would give
that a two i'd give that a two
they could be sleeping in your attic and
you wouldn't even know it
that's what special operations is like
that's why that's what i like to think
about you know
being a ninja it's like being a ninja